song like medicine
seems to be really important
to people
who
either want to come out or are having
trouble with um you know being accepted
for their sexuality
is that a fair statement you think uh
i'd say yeah there's definitely a part
of it in there yeah and they say that a
lot of kids who come to your shows
suddenly i don't know what it is they
get the confidence or the wherewithal to
say [ __ ] it
i'm gonna live my life authentically i
mean i think like it's it's definitely
i'd say feeling like
there is a there's a space where people
feel safe enough to kind of share
to
i guess
have those big moments and obviously
share them with
a room full of people and share them
with us in a way
is um
you know probably one of the things i'm
most proud of i think
in
you know again in in a lot of ways like
i i
actually don't think that is as much
about me as it maybe seems i think the
atmosphere that i feel is created in the
room of the shows that we do is
this kind of like free um incredibly
like emotionally generous uh atmosphere
and it's kind of
one of the things that
i feel like when people come and see a
show it's one of the first
you know two things that people comment
on is you know i've just never been in
an atmosphere like that it just feels so
like safe it's like a room it's like a
family full of strangers who are all
kind of
feeling this like free evening and it's
kind of an escape and
i think like the fans create that
atmosphere more so than me i think they
have
obviously created that for me to feel
but you're the lightning rod harry i
mean because you're willing to go up on
stage and dress the way you want to and
singing about things that uh perhaps
encourage that freedom i mean you're
you're the catalyst for that i mean i'd
say i wouldn't say i was a catalyst i'd
say i was more of a mirror because i
think i only
have that space on stage to feel
kind of free enough to be whoever i am
because i think it's an environment that
both the fans and you know people in my
life my friends have have created for me
to feel
like i can be whoever i want but don't
you think there's some weird [ __ ] going
down in this country right now where are
a lot of rights uh not just a woman's
right to use but there's some weird vibe
going on where p there's a backlash yeah
i could see gay marriage going out the
window i could see a lot of this [ __ ] uh
disappearing some of the freedoms that
people have been enjoying yeah i think i
think there is you know
for
a while and in some places in in our
culture like there's a lot of people who
are taking i think the right steps to
try and make positive things happening
and i think obviously people who don't
like that
are kind of clawing to
grapple back any
ground that they feel like they've lost
which never belonged to them in the
first place i just don't think anyone
should be able to make decisions about
anyone else's body it doesn't it doesn't
really make any sense to me i think
there's a level of obviously what's
happening here in the country at the
moment is
i don't really know where that ends like
you know at that point is it
you know someone needs an operation and
someone can decide that they can't have
it and
um
it just it makes no sense to me i think
we live in a world where we feel like
we're always making the right steps and
there's a lot of people who are taking
positive steps
and i think it's it's quite scary to see
kind of like just how far backwards
we're going in a lot of ways